there's a lot of japanese food out there
that i feel just gets completely swept
under the rug because again
the whole western perception is ramen
and sushi
that's it that's okay all japan has to
offer okay i mean i i think okonomiyaki
is okay okonomiyaki not is like you take
that back
you [ __ ] take that [ __ ] back is like
a good
like pasta and elsewhere like it's like
a carb
filling and it's very like you you know
you can't really get mad at pasta most
of the time
that's okay
that's exactly my point it's just a
savory pancake
and it looks better than it tastes it
because
you see okonomiyaki and it's like the
[ __ ] shokugeki food porn
you could you could watch this thing and
jack off to it basically but when you
actually eat it it's just like
wow this is this is this is this should
be up on them they should be up on the
[ __ ] painting
i'm off to quit this part
just because i've never heard anyone
every time i've taken
a of someone from overseas to an
okonomiyaki place
they've had the food wars experience
it's just street food though it is a
street food but it's probably
the best street food you can have like i
will i will happily take an okonomiyaki
over like a yuck sober
in my opinion maybe
don't get me wrong like all right
noodles it's great okay but like okay so
then
it's all kind of meht here for me it's
like well yeah because it's
it's b grade food right it's street food
of course it's not gonna be like oh my
god this is the best meal i've ever had
it's just
there to fill your stomach right so but
like in no world
if a matsia is nearby am i not going to
choose matt matzia is the definition of
b grapefruit what are you talking about
yeah but like that's what i'm saying
it's it's the king of the only
difference between matzia
and street food is that matsuya has a
logo
that's the only difference it's
comfortable man it's comfortable
yeah sure i saw a cockroach run across
the floor one time yeah right i don't
give a [ __ ] the food tastes amazing okay
so then if matias started making like
yuck sober and okonomiyaki would you eat
it no what the [ __ ]
that's the difference i get the same
because dude the beef bowls are like if
we're talking b
grade food in japan yeah beef bowls and
pork balls are the king
oh yeah of course but they're not good
but you're not going to get a restaurant
but you're not going to get a beef bowl
and a pork ball at a [ __ ] summer
festival
you're going to get an okonomiyaki yeah
when i get to summer festival i'm like
yo this is sick uh google maps where's
the nearest
jesus matsuri i never want to go to a
summer festival with you
yeah we're just going to end up in a
[ __ ] matzia no because like
when we went i think aki got like all
the [ __ ] weird seafood i'm like oh
that's cool that's really cool
yeah it's got a restaurant as the
certified japanese person
that's why i am now i'm the certified
japanese person of trash taste that's
all i am
taking why is anyone taking my opinion
on food i'm white
what are the japanese dishes that people
should know
outside of just ramen and sushi and now
we've mentioned suki man yeah i i feel
that
again it's it's a lot of like i mean
we've exp we've already touched upon a
lot of them right like
this one is definitely another one uh
yakitori
yakitori like just a lot of uh well [ __ ]
a lot of uh street food like just be
great street food like yeah you know as
much as you guys say that it's me like i
reckon
not enough people oh no try okay
they destroy an okonomiyaki don't get me
wrong but i'm not going to feel happy
about it yeah
here's the thing right i feel like movie
japan has just completely shifted my
perception of what good food is yeah
because you give me this [ __ ] when i
come from england
everything's like ester everything in
japan is like st
compared to like what you can get in
england yeah and then you live here
you're like man there's different tiers
of stuff yeah there's like a single st
there's a triple s
yeah i saw an article shared around on
twitter it was basically like
why does japan and switzerland have such
a high like baseline for what should be
like standard
right yeah in terms of like just
everything in life right right
especially food like just public
transport like daily living like
just everything in life has such a high
minimum requirement
in japan in the uk it's like i could pay
like a hundred pounds and get a [ __ ]
garbage meal
right right right in japan it's just not
gonna happen yeah if you pay more than
normal here you will just get something
good
you'll get an experience i've never gone
to a restaurant here where i've paid
more than like the baseline and been
disappointed
yeah yeah and even then like i said like
like the mancia's right and and the
chains and the really average stuff
it's so good that like anywhere you go
in japan if you're
not from here you'll probably be really
satisfied with it yeah and
[ __ ] it must be awful being japanese and
traveling overseas and being like
wait this restaurant was [ __ ] yeah i
just paid a hundred pounds
yeah yeah and it was garbage how is this
legal yeah
they know it's [ __ ] right yeah of course
they do they don't give a [ __ ] though
they don't give a [ __ ] they don't care
yeah i don't know it's just really
interesting like
and and yeah that is the baseline i
think is why
when anyone asks you like what is your
favorite thing about japan i'm sure
we can all agree that it's probably top
three of like food the food yeah food is
amazing
i mean i knew i was gonna like the anime
yeah yeah
of course yeah and yeah is hamburger on
its own a devastation to hamburgers
worldwide yeah it is
but is it still gonna be better than any
other country that does it
honestly yeah it is it's going to be
better like i'll admit that much that's
the thing
is that i think a lot of people who
haven't come to japan or know nothing
about the japanese food culture here i
think that
when people say the food is just better
in japan yeah
people i think people are just quick to
be like oh they think japanese food is
better in japan of course it is no no
every food is better let me just tell
you like this
it just don't miss okay no matter where
you go in japan
no matter where you go in japan you
don't miss i know and even like
foreign foods like italian food is such
a unique flavor here but in a really
good way
the way i see it is italian food in
japan is the way that new york pizza is
to pizza
yeah yeah it's a it's a totally
different take on it that's
still really still works yeah it's
really good yeah and i feel like it's
the same way with a lot of the food they
have here
yeah and so i love people ask oh you
know can you get like authentic it might
not be authentic
but who the [ __ ] gives a [ __ ] if it's
authentic if it tastes good and it's
amazing
who cares i mean we've recently found
like an indian uh like
one there yeah that's very authentic
yeah it's authentic but
and it was also still yeah yeah yeah
yeah [ __ ] good right amazing like
just like destroyed my [ __ ] stomach
like oh yeah
the next day and and i'm not destroying
my [ __ ] toilet that's not appropriate
it's not a good car
it's not a proper indian i want to be
like doubting it every single every
single moment
until it's in my mouth yeah i'm like i
made the right decision
yeah if i wake up in the morning and i
don't know if it's a fart or a shot
that's
how you know it's a good career meline
pointed something out before we end uh
unagi
unagi is god tier it's like oh my god oh
my god
something we all agree on yeah do we all
agree on yes eat the eat the unagi
unagi is it's like a boiled uh eel and
then it's grilled and
in this like beautiful sauce yeah i
don't even know how to describe it
and they just they just serve it on the
rice and it don't get me wrong it's very
expensive
it is but it is worth the price it's a
summer food and
it is you eat it and you feel clean you
feel happy
but you're getting that fillingness that
you get from other stuff yeah it's so
good
it's so weird because eating unagi is
like in the middle of eating
fish and meat yeah i can't explain i
can't explain it like
it it feels like a fish but it is
feeling like
it sits like a meat yeah it's just like
a meal sounds like something that like i
think a lot of westerners
i mean i know if you told me eel yeah i
don't want to eat eel yeah yeah
but it it falls apart it doesn't taste
fishy at all it's so
good yeah okay it's expensive like i
think when we went to one
we went to a really fancy one where you
paid like 60 bucks [ __ ] paid 68 bucks
for me i know that's too much i
i know that's a lot but like my brain
just turned off i didn't look at the
price i
i just i wanted the large one yeah the
large one it was like two and a half
eels
yeah of this and i was like yeah oh it
was really [ __ ] good it was really
interesting
this is so [ __ ] good yeah and like if
you come here during the summer
i highly recommend it i think it is by
far the best summer food in japan easily
i don't think there's anything close to
it
winter food a lot of heavyweight
contenders bro but yeah summer i think
unani is the king
yeah yeah so in summation if you ever
come to japan apart from the
usual of ramen and sushi that you're
going to try anyway
regardless of what we said it's good get
inagi you can never go wrong with that
tsukemen
yeah we need more people in the culture
i mean
i need to build this cult the cold
tsukemen sashimi
this is the only cult that you're going
to be later for
for me don't get curry no matter where
you get curry
if you've never tried curry before try
it japanese if japanese curry but if you
have tried curry before
it's to me it's going to taste exactly
the same as it is everywhere
sober try soba you know some healthy
noodles try udon just to confirm you
don't like it
bottom line there's way more to japanese
food than ramen and sushi there's
so much more and i guarantee everything
you'll try here is either going to be
some kind of just
a positive experience or just something
life-changing yeah but before we end it
i want to say that
like when you eat food here like you
almost want to cry because you just feel
like someone cares
like you you feel like someone really
cares right i almost did cry when i yeah
we've already talked about that all the
food you're like
[ __ ] man someone really [ __ ] cared
about the quality here
that doesn't make you tear up every
single time you have a bite of food i
don't know what will
i never thought i'd [ __ ] almost cry
over [ __ ] noodles but
here i was there's yeah and it's the
same thing like fruit right like they
have that saying of like you know
the reason why it's so expensive because
so much love is putting yeah yeah
you do really feel like i know it's
cheesy as [ __ ] and i think it's dumb as
[ __ ] when they say it but i
you when you eat that food you do feel
like every single step of the process
yeah everyone for some
but in japan you actually kind of
genuinely feel like okay yeah you feel
you feel the love
yeah yeah it looks like it's pride
there's so much pride in every single
piece of food that you eat yeah and
you can just taste it and yeah just
honestly when you come here go on google
maps
if it's over four stars it's going to be
amazing i guarantee it just go
everywhere trust me because they are
[ __ ]
strict because when you compliment the
chefs they really they they're like
they actually like appreciate that this
is the only place on earth where i've
actually wanted to be like
do the meme where it's like can you call
this chef everybody yeah no no yeah
i need to shake his hand man yeah this
man this man's general masterpiece
yeah like if i ever get the opportunity
i like thank the chef yeah